the defendant put her in her freezer
thereafter he went to Home Depot bought
cement bought wood grew some details of
the murder of a young woman who police
say was killed by this man and today we
are one step closer to learning that
man's fate Aid who's now the only
station in court for a somewhat
unexpected plea deal on a murder we've
been covering now for three years 87
investigator Kyle Payne was there as the
details Kyle my colleague Vanessa Murphy
has covered this case since 2019 when 24
year old Esmeralda Gonzalez met a brutal
end now prestepino is taking a deal that
acts the same as admitting he did it
without admitting he did it
my colleagues and I have spent the
weekend yelling and screaming and
fighting and we actually do have a
mutually agreeable resolution it's a
resolution nobody was expecting because
last week the lawyers and defendant were
in court saying their negotiations had
stalled
negotiations but the negotiations are
are giving the killer better end of the
deal and we have proof and statements
that that's saying that she said she did
it that's the defendant Christopher
prestepino arguing that his co-defendant
and roommate Cassandra Garrett might be
getting a better deal the two are
accused of luring the victim Esmerelda
Gonzalez into their home plying her with
drugs injecting her with pool cleaner
and leaving her for dead in this
homemade coffin it was made of cement
wood and other materials that he had
previously bought at Home Depot do you
understand that you are being charged
with first degree kidnapping and
secondary money yes sir how do you
preview those two charges he'll be
pursuant to Alfred and Alfred plea use
usually used by a defendant whose best
interests are served by pleading guilty
but maintains his innocence in this case
agreeing to the set of facts the
prosecutor would present a trial do you
understand it means that we won't have a
trial in this case which was scheduled
to start at 1pm today yes
so no trial after all and maybe because
the plea agreement came together so
quickly neither the defendants nor the
victim's family were present in the
courtroom we asked prosecutors if the
victim's family had signed off on the
offer and hadn't immediately gotten a
response we will keep asking
Kyle thank you prestepino is facing up
to 25 years in prison his girlfriend
pleaded guilty to an accessory to murder
charge in 2020 serving less than two
years